With Warner Brothers' decision to simultaneously
release their 2021 slate of films in theaters
and on HBO Max, there's lots to look forward
to from the comfort of your own home.
From sci-fi spectacles to prestige dramas
and documentaries, here are the must-watch
movies coming to HBO Max in 2021 and beyond.
Mortal Kombat fans have been not-so-patiently
waiting for nearly 25 years for another Mortal
Kombat movie to be released in theaters.
Video game movies have a track record of being
subpar, and Mortal Kombat certainly has a
part to play in that history.
Not counting the direct-to-video release of
Mortal Kombat Legends: Scorpion's Revenge
in 2020, the last Mortal Kombat movie was
the poorly received Mortal Kombat: Annihilation
in 1997.
Even as a sequel to the beloved 1995 original
film, Annihilation was enough of a failure
to completely end the Mortal Kombat film franchise.
Until now.
Ever since Warner Brothers acquired Midway
Games in 2009, fans have been anticipating
a new Mortal Kombat, which is finally hitting
theaters and HBO Max on April 23, 2021.
"Get over here!"
The movie is getting off on the right foot
by casting martial arts and stunt professionals
from across the globe, including Lewis Tan
and Joe Taslim.
And along with actors such as Mehcad Brooks,
Jessica McNamee, Josh Lawson, and Hiroyuki
Sanada, the cast is a good indicator that
the new Mortal Kombat is fully embracing the
fantasy franchise's martial arts tournament
roots.
The trailers so far aren't showing too much
about the story, but if nothing else, expect
some impressive stunts and intricately choreographed
hand-to-hand fights.
If you're a fan of dark, modern-day Westerns,
then keep your eyes on HBO Max.
Those Who Wish Me Dead is based on the novel
of the same title, one written by Michael
Koryta and published in 2014.
Koryta is one of the credited screenwriters
on the project, alongside Charles Leavitt
and director Taylor Sheridan.
Those Who Wish Me Dead stars Angelina Jolie
and Nicholas Hoult in lead roles, along with
Tyler Perry, Aidan Gillen and Jon Bernthal.
Filmed in New Mexico, the movie is actually
set in the wilderness of Montana, in a forest
threatened by wildfires.
This white-knuckle thriller finds a teenage
murder witness being pursued by twin assassins.
Needless to say, that's not a great situation
to find yourself in, but at least this teen
has the assistance of a survival expert tasked
with protecting him.
Those Who Wish Me Dead is sure to be an intense
ride for its characters while also being a
commentary on the state of the environment.
The film is set to hit HBO Max and theaters
on May 14, 2021.
The Conjuring universe has grown a lot since
we were first introduced to the world of the
Warrens in 2013.
Since then, we've met the likes of La Llorona
and Valak, and we've run into that creepy
Annabelle doll on more than one occasion.
Now, we're returning to the main storyline
with the eighth film in the franchise — The
Conjuring: The Devil Made Me Do It.
Patrick Wilson and Vera Farmiga are returning
as real-life paranormal investigators and
authors Ed and Lorraine Warren.
Originally scheduled for a September 2020
release, The Devil Made Me Do It was delayed
due to COVID-19 and will now be out June 4,
2021.
It's directed by relative newcomer Michael
Chaves, who is best known to Conjuring fans
as the director of The Curse of La Llorona,
the sixth film in the Conjuring universe.
The Devil Made Me Do It is based on the trial
of Arne Cheyenne Johnson, who was the first
murder suspect to ever claim demonic possession
as a defense.
The 1981 case also involved the possession
of an 11-year-old boy, which is certain to
be the source of many scares in the upcoming
Conjuring film.
The Devil Made Me Do It hits HBO Max June
4, 2021.
Before Hamilton, In the Heights was the musical
that put Lin-Manuel Miranda on the Broadway
map.
Featuring his characteristic pop-rap style
of songwriting, the story of his first show
is much more grounded than the bombastic historical
hit.
A community in Washington Heights has to deal
with the sweltering heat of a New York summer
while working through issues of family, race,
and class.
"They're talking about kicking out all the
Dreamers.
It's time to make some noise."
The film adaptation of In the Heights is directed
by Jon M. Chu, and features one of Hamilton's
youngest stars, Anthony Ramos, in the lead
role.
Originally scheduled to be released in the
summer of 2020, In the Heights will finally
release in theaters and on HBO Max on June
11, 2021.
For decades now, fans have been clamoring
for a sequel to Space Jam.
The 1996 Looney Tunes and Michael Jordan crossover
is still the highest-grossing basketball movie
of all time, begging the question of why it's
taken so long for Hollywood to make a new
installment.
But in 2021, Space Jam: A New Legacy will
finally bring the Space Jam magic to a new
generation.
This time, the basketball star at the center
of the story is LeBron James.
Trapped in a virtual reality space with his
son by a rogue A.I., played by Don Cheadle,
James has to team up with the Looney Toons
to beat a team of elite basketball-playing
algorithms.
Directed by Malcolm D. Lee and produced by
Ryan Coogler, Space Jam: A New Legacy is sure
to be a blast for families and kids.
Even if you're not a fan of Bugs Bunny and
company, there will be something for everyone
in this wacky flick, as James' journey through
virtual reality will tie into other Warner
Brothers films such as Casablanca and Mad
Max: Fury Road.
The game starts on July 16, 2021.
Written and directed by Guardians of the Galaxy
director James Gunn, The Suicide Squad serves
as a soft reboot of the 2016 film of nearly
the same name.
While the 2021 film keeps Margot Robbie as
Harley Quinn, as well as Joel Kinnaman's Rick
Flag, Viola Davis' Amanda Waller, and Jai
Courtney's Captain Boomerang, the majority
of the 2016 cast isn't returning for the new
film.
Instead, the movie is opting for a fresh start,
with new actors playing new characters.
The impressive and eclectic cast of The Suicide
Squad includes Idris Elba as Bloodsport, John
Cena as Peacemaker, Sylvester Stallone as
King Shark, Michael Rooker as Savant, and
Pete Davidson as Blackguard, among a host
of other actors.
A spinoff show starring John Cena's Peacemaker
is already in the works and slated for the
2022 HBO Max lineup.
Between the cast and the adult tone projected,
The Suicide Squad looks to be a funny, bombastic
alternative to the the more serious side of
the DCEU, and -- true to its name -- already
promises a high body count.
"We're all going to die."
"I hope so."
Seeming to follow in the chaotic footsteps
of Birds of Prey, the largely doomed team
of The Suicide Squad is coming to town on
August 6, 2021.
Reminiscence is an upcoming sci-fi thriller
starring Hugh Jackman that looks to be channeling
Inception, which isn't all that surprising
considering Reminiscence is a collaboration
between producer Jonathan Nolan and his wife,
director Lisa Joy, who previously co-created
HBO's Westworld.
Not much is known about the intriguing film
outside of its premise.
Jackman plays Nick Bannister, an ex-military
man with certain professional skills.
For the right price, he can offer the chance
for people to relive any memory they desire.
When he falls in love with Mae, played by
Rebecca Ferguson, things get complicated when
he gains access to her memories, and the truth
about her dark past starts to come to the
surface.
If you like action, sci-fi, or thrillers,
Reminiscence is a can't-miss watch when it
comes to HBO Max on September 3, 2021.
Only a few months after a new Conjuring movie
hits, we get Malignant, and it's sure to scare
our pants off.
Aside from this being Conjuring universe creator
James Wan's first time directing a horror
movie since 2016's The Conjuring 2, it also
features a face that might be familiar to
audiences who absolutely love being terrified.
Annabelle Wallis, who is best known for her
role as Mia in the first Annabelle film, has
a starring role in Malignant.
Wan has said that Malignant isn't based on
any pre-existing movie or story.
It's a completely original horror thriller,
but beyond that, not a whole lot else is known.
It's probably best that way, too.
There's nothing better to a horror fan than
a completely surprising and terrifying moviegoing
experience.
Get ready for some major scares on September
10, 2021.
Years after the ambiguous ending of The Sopranos,
fans of HBO's era-defining mob epic are finally
getting invited back into the life of Tony
Soprano and his family.
Only this time, it's a prequel.
The Many Saints of Newark is a collaboration
between Warner Brothers and HBO Films that
was originally scheduled for theatrical release
in September 2020.
Like many of the Warner Brothers features
on this list, The Many Saints of Newark was
delayed exactly one year and will hit a simultaneous
release in theaters and streaming on HBO Max.
This prequel to the acclaimed drama series
is set in the 1960s and '70s in New Jersey.
Penned by Sopranos series creator David Chase,
The Many Saints of Newark aims to tell a story
about the 1967 Newark riots.
The film will focus on the racial tensions
between the Italian-American and African-American
communities of New Jersey and the Eastern
seaboard.
The cast is loaded, with Corey Stoll as a
young Junior Soprano and James Gandolfini's
son, Michael, cast as a young Tony.
Plus, we've got Vera Farmiga as Livia Soprano,
in addition to appearances from Jon Bernthal,
Leslie Odom Jr., and Ray Liotta.
Sopranos fans will have a lot to be thankful
for this fall, when the gangsters make their
way to HBO Max on September 24, 2021.
Denis Villeneuve's take on Dune is one of
the most hyped movies of 2021, following an
entire year of being one of the most hyped
movies of 2020.
Still, the excitement persists with each morsel
of news that comes out.
For sci-fi fans of many ages, Dune is a fundamental
work — a cornerstone of the genre — and
this version looks to get a lot of things
right where David Lynch's 1984 attempt to
adapt it failed.
Timothee Chalamet takes the reins as Dune
hero Paul Atreides, and Oscar Isaac will appear
as his father, Duke Leto Atreides.
This will be the first entry in Villeneuve's
two-part adaptation of the first novel in
the Frank Herbert series.
The rest of the cast includes Rebecca Ferguson,
Javier Bardem, Josh Brolin, Zendaya, Stellan
Skarsgård, Jason Momoa, and Dave Bautista.
So, if you're ready to visit the world of
Arrakis, just remember that fear is the mind-killer
and that Dune will be hitting HBO Max on October
1, 2021.
If you're a fan of films like Hang 'Em High,
The Outlaw Josey Wales, or The Good, the Bad
and the Ugly, have we got some great news
for you.
Cry Macho is the next Western from Clint Eastwood.
It's based on the 1975 book of the same name,
written by N. Richard Nash, who co-wrote the
screenplay in the '90s with Nick Schenk prior
to Nash's death in the year 2000.
And as you've probably assumed, Eastwood is
not only showing up in front of the camera,
but also sitting in the director's seat.
The film will be a neo-Western, meaning it's
set closer to the modern day than the heyday
of cowboys in the 1800s.
Still, we're pretty sure the Academy Award-winning
director of Unforgiven will handle the century
change just fine.
Eastwood stars as a washed-up rodeo star and
20th century cowboy.
In 1978, he takes a job from an ex-boss to
bring the man's young son home and away from
his alcoholic mother.
The film was shot in New Mexico in November
and December of 2020.
If you're excited to see Eastwood back in
the proverbial saddle, Cry Macho will ride
onto HBO Max on October 22, 2021.
Slated as one of HBO Max's big releases of
the 2021 holiday season, King Richard is setting
itself up as an awards-season contender.
The Warner Brothers biopic stars Will Smith
as Richard Williams, father of tennis superstars
Venus and Serena Williams.
The film is a look at their father's influence
and how Richard coached them to success.
King Richard features Saniyya [sa-NIE-ah]
Sidney and Demi Singleton as Venus and Serena,
respectively.
Jon Bernthal, Tony Goldwyn, and Dylan McDermott
are also going to make appearances in supporting
roles.
Liev Schreiber was originally cast, but was
replaced by Goldwyn in October of 2020.
Not much else is known about the film aside
from its talent and premise.
The script was penned by Zach Baylin, and
Monsters and Men director Reinaldo Marcus
Green was brought on to helm the project.
Anyone looking for more serious drama fare
on HBO Max is sure to perk their ears up when
King Richard gets a release on the streaming
service later this year, especially Will Smith
fans and tennis aficionados.
The match begins on November 19, 2021.
It's been quite a long time since we've seen
a new project set in the world of The Matrix.
The pivotal cyberpunk franchise has laid dormant
since the multiplayer role playing game The
Matrix Online went offline in 2009.
But over a decade later — and nearly two
decades since the last movie — Lana Wachowski
is returning to direct a fourth live-action
Matrix movie.
While the film doesn't yet have a title, Resurrections
has been heavily rumored as a potential option.
"Whoa."
Although Lilly Wachowski worked with Lana
on the original Matrix trilogy, as well as
most of the sisters' other projects, she is
not returning for this brand new Matrix film.
The production on the fourth Matrix movie
was interrupted by the COVID-19 shutdown,
but it resumed filming in the summer of 2020
and wrapped up in November.
Of course, no matter how fascinating the world
of The Matrix is, a new Matrix movie would
be nothing without Neo.
Thankfully, both Keanu Reeves and Carrie-Anne
Moss are returning to the series as Neo and
Trinity, respectively.
Jada Pinkett Smith, Daniel Bernhardt, and
Lambert Wilson will also be reprising their
roles from the Matrix sequels.
Sadly, Laurence Fishburne has gone on the
record saying he wasn't asked to return to
his iconic role as Morpheus.
Still, the cast isn't without its fair share
of star power.
Yahya Abdul-Mateen II, Priyanka Chopra, Neil
Patrick Harris, and Jonathan Groff will all
be making appearances in the newest movie
when it releases on December 22, 2021.
Based on the J.T. Rogers play that took the
world by storm in 2017 and won a Tony for
Best Play, Oslo is an upcoming film adaptation
from producers Steven Spielberg and Marc Platt.
Rogers wrote the screenplay, and the adaptation
is being directed by Bartlett Sher, who directed
Oslo on Broadway and earned a Tony nomination
for his work.
With Andrew Scott of Fleabag and Ruth Wilson
of The Affair in the leading roles, this version
of Oslo is shaping up to be the real deal.
The plot of the film will tell the story of
the secret 1990s Oslo Peace Accords between
Israel and the Palestinian Liberation Organization.
In other words, it's a story about people
from wildly different backgrounds trying to
build relationships and the struggles they
face due to overwhelming political turmoil
and change.
And since this film is based on an award-winning
play and backed by some very successful producers,
it's clear that HBO wants this project to
be a major hit.
So while there's no release date for Oslo
yet, it's likely to hit the streaming service
later in 2021, just in time for awards season.
In the Same Breath is the first of two HBO
Films documentaries slated for release on
HBO Max sometime in 2021.
This one is HBO's exposé on the COVID-19
outbreak and how it specifically affected
China and the United States.
In the Same Breath takes a look at the government
response from each country and puts it in
a wider global context.
The documentary premiered at Sundance in January
and SXSW Online in March to rave reviews.
It currently holds an outrageously positive
average of 97% on Rotten Tomatoes.
A passion project for Chinese-American director
Nanfu Wang, In the Same Breath focuses on
the widespread governmental failures in handling
the pandemic response by taking a deeper look
at the two countries Wang has lived in.
After receiving such a positive reception
following its festival premiere, hopefully
it will find its way onto HBO Max before the
end of 2021.
Like the rest of Hollywood, HBO Films is champing
at the bit to capitalize on the GameStop stock
market anomaly that occurred early in 2021.
Already, Hulu has released its documentary,
GameStopped, and a number of other projects
are in the works from other studios, including
an MGM film, two Netflix projects, and a feature
documentary by Console Wars director Jonah
Tulis.
However, we're pretty sure that HBO's documentary
will be something special, given the studio's
past track record for creating critically
acclaimed documentaries.
While the project is still in its earliest
stages, Andrew Ross Sorkin of TBTF Productions,
Len Amato of Crash&Salvage, and Jason Blum
of Blumhouse are all on board to serve as
executive producers for the film.
TV fans probably know Sorkin best as co-creator
of the TV drama Billions.
It's an interesting mix of producers that
will hopefully result in a fascinating exposé
of one of the most interesting companies of
the year.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.